hi sorry i'm late
we're a regular session where we uh
compare notes on language learning
so i get into uh youtube where i
normally uh go to my account and look
for creators studio and from there
go to events and then i find these
events that have been scheduled and i
start the discussion
however yesterday my uh
what do you call it there
chrome kept on
um
dying on me
and so i figured maybe there was
something in my computer so i shut my
computer down
and force quit everything you know and
shut it down let the computer rest for a
while
and then i started it up again i guess
as a result of doing that when i opened
up my youtube there was no evidence of
creator studio anywhere
and so i was you know frantically
looking for it and then i suddenly
noticed that i had to sign in again so i
signed in and once again i found my way
here so sorry that i am late
today i want to talk about
sort of and the reason all these what
happens to me i said i do all these
different things and i always relate
them to language learning now
when you play golf which is one of my
main activities down here in palm
springs my wife is very keen on golf and
so i go with her and she beats me
but uh certainly if you stand over the
golf ball
and you start and you try to think
about where to position your elbow your
knee and harder your turn and all this
other stuff you can't hit the ball it
has to at some point become
a natural movement
and
of course if you ever take lessons in
golf
every
pro gives you slightly different things
or even worse if you read an article in
a magazine
or see a video on youtube with some more
brilliant advice on how you should move
your hips or turn your shoulders or
any of this stuff it just fills your
brain
with
sometimes contradictory advice or even
if it's not contradictory all of these
things which are very difficult to do
when you're swinging the golf club
and
so it was just funny because for my
wife's birthday i gave her a watch
which uh it tells the distance to the
next you know to the hole and all this
kind of stuff when you're playing golf
and
it measures your tempo and so i was
using it on the driving range
and the goal is to make sure that you
have an even tempo so you're swinging
you know ideally you have you take three
times as long in your back swing as in
your actual swing through the ball so
you go one two three one okay and so i
was doing that for a while and if all i
focused on was that tempo my golf swing
improved the more i thought about the
position of my hands and position on
impact and then you know weight transfer
and this kind of stuff the worse i was
uh but as i if i had one very simple
natural
room boom
uh my golf swing improved now i haven't
taken that to the golf course yet so
it's often easy to do well on the
driving range and then get to the golf
course and then all of these doubts come
in your mind and should i be doing this
and that and something else
however it made me think of
uh languages
so
you know uh of course i'm very much i
mean my main language learning activity
is input reading and listening
acquiring the language trying to
understand i enjoy it i explore
i like the sound of new languages i like
this hearing the structures noticing
some of the structures all that is thing
those are things that i like to do but
ultimately i also like to speak
so
you know i had my uh farsi or persian
discussion
um with rana yesterday and
yeah i got some things right something
wrong and struggled and whatnot and she
sent me a report
which i work on and i'm also listening
to some material that i've listened to
before like the assimil material
so i proceed with that but i do like to
speak well now i am not bothered by
making mistakes
but there are people who are and i get
regular messages from people saying yeah
i read i listen but when i go to speak i
i you know i'm
hopeless or i'm not good or whatever
so my uh i thought to myself well you
know what the way to overcome that is to
say you know do whatever you can and in
terms of reading and listening and
enjoying the language and if you like
reading grammar read grammar it really
doesn't matter but when you go to speak
forget all that stuff just like me on
the golf course forget all of that
whatever i have done whatever i saw
videos about my hand my hip my knees
forget it when you're on the golf course
you just swing the club boom
boom that's what i'm gonna do in fact
we're playing this afternoon
and so with the language the same when
you go to speak
just speak
whatever you acquired through your
various processes of whatever you were
doing it doesn't matter whether you're
on link whether you're reading whether
you're doing anki whether you're
studying grammar books it really doesn't
matter what matters is that when you go
to speak
just speak don't even think about all
those things because it's only going to
cramp your style
whatever comes out comes out
uh trust your instincts
some may be correct some may be wrong if
you keep on speaking
keep on listening and reading you won't
get worse you'll only get better so that
to me it's a language it's a natural
process of acquisition
you know you see on and of course
teachers like to complicate things uh
you need special instruction you need uh
to the i don't know pre-reading
questions and post-reading questions and
people need to be taught how to listen
and and to chunk and to uh
yeah i don't know taught how to listen
i don't believe any of that i think you
just
as stephen crash has said if you have
interesting material oh speaking of
interesting material
uh i do intend to work on my korean
uh
in preparation for fukuoka
and so um i mean speaking of golf so i
noticed our i'm my wife sometimes looks
at this korean golfer amy who does
videos on golf
and she does them in english and she
speaks english very well but i
discovered that she has some videos in
korean
so i thought well i don't need them now
but just as an experiment
i used the link
import browser
so i just opened up the youtube
video her one of her videos which is in
korean turned on the closed captions
hit the uh import browser button on my
uh
chrome and lo and behold i now have a
lesson on golf
in korean i have the text
i have the video and i can take the
audio away and listen to it if i want
now i am interested in what she has to
say
so
the ideal content for language learning
is content that you're interested in
because now you're you're just you're
just kind of looking at the words
getting past that i'm not doing this to
learn korean i'm doing it because i'm
interested in what she has to say so
she's got a lot of videos in korean and
that's going to be great learning
material for me when i decided to go
after
to refresh and renew and hopefully
improve my career but again it'll be
this natural process and then when i go
to speak i'll just speak i'll speak with
whatever i have that's what comes out
that's what you get
and um
keep doing it and you improve it's not
more complicated it's again like this
thing in teaching in general uh teachers
get into this learning styles are you a
kinetic learner a visual learner and
stuff and that's been totally debunked
there's absolutely no basis in fact for
the idea that different people have
different ways of learning we all learn
the same way we may have things that we
prefer doing some people prefer reading
some people prefer listening some people
prefer doing anki those are preferences
but the way the brain learns the
language is the same for everyone it's
just one example of the many ways in
which the sort of
teaching industry over complicates what
is actually a very natural process the
brain will when exposed to enough
stimulus and experience sort things out
and create patterns that enables the
brain to sort of deal with it and it's a
constant process
of learning the brain learns cannot do
otherwise than learn but it doesn't take
time and if you are emotionally
committed to the process interested in
what you're listening to and reading i
think you learned even better so that's
what i had to say and now i want to see
if we have any
comments or questions from people who
are watching this
uh okay so let me get to the beginning
here
blah blah blah any sight to read news in
korean all right
um
you know if you are
a
if you are a learner you have to find
things on your own it's not difficult to
find
news sites in korea you can look in
english korean newspapers and some will
be
linked to the korean language website
you can translate it at google translate
and search for it so i i'm not even
going to give an answer but all of the
major korean newspapers have websites
okay
thanks for doing these videos
and your new inspiration to me when i
come i'm glad to hear that always makes
me happy to hear that i'm able to
influence people to become enthusiastic
language learners
yeah very little deliberate learning hi
steven
[Music]
the
okay i mean
my position is always
if we get enough content in the language
we will add it
and this typically means at the very
least the 60 mini stories
and we're currently working on georgian
right now so if someone can add that
inherit then we'll add it
and we're learning a language is
starting to speak how often do you
usually take lessons with the tutor and
how long are your sessions okay
i would say that in the past i used to
wait till i had
you know
five six seven thousand words ten
thousand words so maybe
six months
in the case of check for example
uh but now uh the mini stores enabled me
to start earlier
so i started uh
i started persian after almost like a
thousand words or so greek i started
after a few thousand words arabic after
three thousand words how often i think
once or twice a week is enough because
it's time that's taken away from your
input activity but it's a stimulus you
want to get better
you get some feedback
uh but i think that's enough now once
you are good in the language you
actually have to speak a lot so i think
at a later stage i might want to speak
more often
no yeah if you accept you're gonna make
errors you'll do better absolutely it's
about to bring that the long gone
progress and meaning into alignment if
you really you want that
high is it possible to bring back the
long gone progress and meaning
you want that and you aren't making you
aren't letting go of it for a decade
even if i
i must admit i just don't understand the
question uh
oh so nina's unhappy look
you have to
put in some initial effort in order to
get to where you can actually
start to work with interesting content
uh
so that period might be two three months
for
languages similar to ones you already
know it could be a little bit longer
and then you should go for things that
you're interested in and i suggest
bringing them into link
and now you're actually doing things of
interest
so then it doesn't matter how quickly
you're progressing because you're
actually dealing with stuff that's of
interest to you and then when you have
an opportunity to speak you speak and
you don't worry about how you do
with the knowledge that you will
actually get better
i've been learning german for two years
but still can't hold a conversation you
know german isn't the language that you
can speak without caring about grammar
okay
this is mariam nas you know what
it was only when i stopped worrying
about grammar that my german improved as
long as i was trying to remember case
endings
uh dead mdas etc i never i couldn't
speak the language and once i said that
doesn't matter i will naturally improve
i need words i need to understand what
people are saying i can throw words
together even if they're grammatically
incorrect people will understand what
i'm saying and if i can engage with
people i will improve
so
uh you can review the grammar from time
to time in my experience
you can't remember the grammar rules you
can't remember the tables of endings you
seem to you need to you can review them
it might help a little bit
you simply need to engage with the
language hopefully in a way that you
find interesting and enjoyable
thank you so much t for link is the best
app to learn languages i use it every
day thank you very much
blah blah blah do you think it is still
worthwhile to read a book without an
online dictionary even if the unknown
okay it's not a matter of worthwhile yes
it's worthwhile to read when there is a
20 to 30 percent uh unknown words
it's just a little frustrating
because you have
basically a choice you can either look
up all the words you don't know
you'll forget them you can write them
out on a list you'll never look at the
list again it's very difficult to
because very often that 20 30
unknown words are the key words that are
giving you you know the
meaning so i prefer not to do it but i
can't say that it has no benefit it
certainly does have a benefit and if you
are very familiar with the context then
you probably can do it if you are not
familiar with the context i think you'll
get very little out of doing that
uh
uh
okay thank you
uh
what do you think about glossika i i
don't know uh
all i know is that the glossika method
uh
is
one based on learning sentences if i'm
not mistaken
and uh i'm sure it can work it's great i
just i'm not
as i've said many times i i prefer to
try to engage with interesting
meaningful content
and what i save at link are words and
phrases because the phrases will often
repeat sentences tend to be unique
so if you have
enough exposure to the language you are
getting exposed to lots of sentences in
interesting content if you save these
some key phrases you're getting
additional concentrated exposure to
certain key phrases to me that's good
enough but i'm sure the glossary method
works as well
is it enough to speak with a tutor even
for 30 minutes per week or is that not
intense enough oh first of all i think i
didn't answer the first question i
normally go for an hour with the tutor
uh
it used to be
i should say this before i had the many
stories where i
i didn't start at as good a level
because the many stories gives me this
give me this concentrated exposure to
very high frequency verbs that gets me
talking so i start right out with 30
minutes before i would start out with
excuse me i started with one hour
before i used to start it with 30
minutes
as for the amount per week i think once
a week is fine
it's fine it's it's just encouraging
get some feedback uh but the bulk of the
work
has to be in in getting the language
into you
and at some point when you're ready
you'll you'll ask you'll want more
uh you know online discussions
uh mr often i could not make it on time
these live streamings how did it go with
your iranian friends at your oh yeah it
went great it went great i spoke uh
iranian with my friends
uh
uh
[Applause]
do you find it uh i'm
until the end of the year they're
starting georgia next year so i'm
looking forward to georgia being online
yeah
well we've been promised it and we'll
see what happens but we have a keener in
georgia who says he can organize to have
these stories done of course the georgia
if we get them we'll put it up and uh
there you go do you find it feasible and
effective to learn 100 more words a day
using anki i don't use anki but using
link i do learn more than 100 words a
day typically depending on the language
most of it is learned incidentally
through my massive listening and reading
hi steve now i'm learning indonesian
it's interesting we have indonesian that
link by the way if that's helpful too
and i think we have the mini stories
uh you can speak german without caring
about the grammar
the grammar doesn't just flow naturally
then it simply means you haven't
acquired enough of the language so he
said me to carry on yep i agree with
that appropriate gender and i mean his
story that she
okay
i have an exam next week at goethe for
german my problem is totally speaking
once i was marked because of my accent
just speak doesn't seem to sink to my
anxiety okay
i mean that's the trouble with
exams and tests they're unnecessary they
create anxiety they cause us to want to
perform for the test
i've mentioned before that in the
english language school system in canada
students pass tests many times a year
for 10 years and at the end of it they
still can't speak french
tests are a bad idea work on improving
all of your skills
uh with regard to the accent i mean you
just have to the more you listen the
more you get these sounds ringing in
your brain the better chance you have of
reproducing them and and focus on the
sounds as you hear them and don't try to
pronounce them as you see them written
because the value of the letters in your
own language is different from what it
is in the language you're learning
uh
and
and besides if they judge you on your
accent that's very foolish they should
judge you on your ability
to express yourself that means to have
the necessary vocabulary to deliver your
thoughts and if you do a lot of
listening you'll start doing it in the
natural word order of the language and
eventually your grammar will improve
hello i'm chinese learning dutch i'm
living the language experience in
learning dutch
okay i mean it's no different uh this is
stone in in the netherlands i mean i
would get a link to work on your dutch
uh i would listen a lot it's got to
start f again it's a natural process the
dutch language whether it be the sounds
the word structure the changing of the
words it's these are things that your
brain is not used to and you have you
cannot deal with as some kind of a
theoretical concept you're theoretically
going to understand how the dutch
language works you can do that but it
won't help very much you have to get it
so that you've listened to so much that
it starts to become natural but when
you're listening of course if you don't
understand what you're listening to then
you have to read it and you have to save
the words and phrases and review them
again and go back and listen again so
it's the same process whether you're a
chinese person in holland whether you're
a dutch person in china it's the same
process lots of listening
okay thank you from gustavo what do you
depend on the aj okay all japanese all
the time again i don't know all these
other processes and there are many
aj att there are many language systems
out there i am very busy with my
language learning and
with helping about uh helping you know
link with these videos and one thing
another playing golf and enjoying my
retirement i can't go chasing every
single uh you know
glossika adjad or other systems that are
out there try them
try them
uh i benefit from learning french during
college but with my plan stunning abroad
in france coming soon how do i speed it
up robert saying you know just you know
i mean i don't know how good your french
is but listening and reading and uh you
know i studied in france for three years
uh as a university student so everything
was in french so my french was quite
good
when i decided uh maybe six or seven
years ago that i wanted to enjoy
french audiobooks so i listened to
french audiobooks literature
my french improved even further so if
you can listen to audiobooks and if you
don't understand them then find and
there's nothing wrong with like balzac
or
19th century literature where you can
find the ebook online or you pay 15
euros or something and get yourself a
modern novel or something you're
interested in find the audiobook the
ebook import the ebook into link walk
around listening to the audio book if
they're parts that you're not clear
about
read them learn the words get that sort
of intensive exposure and if you can
find a book where you like the voice you
like the content
captures you emotionally and that's
going to push your level for french up
uh okay what do you think about physics
books i have no idea digital books like
kindle
oh sorry where are we here what is the
best
i skipped here what is what's the best
way to get through the beginning level
beginning level basically what i do is i
get myself one or two starter books
teach yourself assimil colloquial it
really doesn't matter it's nice to have
a book they talk about some of the
things that happen in the language
you won't necessarily remember them but
it introduces you to how that language
works so i do that and then i do the
mini stories that link i find that they
are the best way to get yourself sort of
get some momentum in the language
because there's so much repetition it's
focused on the most common verbs it that
tells the same story in different tenses
and that's what i do so
uh what do you think about
kindle well kendall i do a lot of
reading on kindle
but kindle doesn't have the
functionality that we have about link
and therefore if i'm reading in a
foreign language i read on my ipad using
link
uh
okay about reading in the language thing
what do you think about okay i've had
that kindle
i think interesting kind of is the
biggest thing missing in language
learning world right now mr sl or miss
slappy white 20 you are absolutely right
we need more intermediate content
so again i challenge you out there
the best intermediate here are the the
things that i find to be intermediate
okay
natural conversations between people
that then are subsequently transcribed
now there is now this automatic
transcription service which may or may
not work for you but conversations
when i was learning german they i found
this series of cassette tapes in those
days of interviews with people on
different german radio stations and they
just took my german level from here to
here
because the typically people use less
complicated vocabulary when they're in
natural conversations so natural
conversations are good i would love to
see in every language like arabic
persian whatever it might be
slightly simplified
history geography
explanations about the country the
culture and stuff like that so
non-fiction is easier than fiction
fiction is the most difficult personally
i'm not a big fan of sort of
fairy stories children's stories or even
simplified versions of say
you know famous novels this kind of
thing i would rather save that
for when i am better at the language so
you know we can all create conversations
and transcribe them in
dutch chinese english arabic whatever
language we speak it has to be the
native speaker and nowadays it's easy
enough to do on your android iphone or
whatever
get it transcribed give it to put it on
another website doesn't matter but if we
get it at link it can be made available
to our learning community yes we need
more intermediate
content i went through french immersion
and i couldn't really speak french until
i started watching french youtubers and
content on my own after high school yeah
now french immersion and my
grandchildren french immersion
does give you
[Music]
comprehension but i find that the kids
that are in french immersion don't speak
very well however because they have very
good comprehension if they were if
they're put in a french environment or
even with a lot of exposure to movie and
youtube they very very quickly catch up
uh do you think that it's better to
dedicate 30 minutes of study or have 30
minutes distribute it through your
entire day well you know i find it
difficult
to sit down if i'm going to sit down and
study it's going to be a minimum of 30
minutes 30 minutes goes by pretty
quickly uh two minutes here two minutes
there i think it doesn't amount to much
so i don't really time myself like if
it's 20 minutes to do the dishes then
i'll listen for 20 minutes but
i think you have to have a minimum of 30
minutes
i have difficulties to learn the cases
in german of course if you try to learn
the cases in german it's very difficult
learn the language don't learn
the cases
what was your favorite russian novel
ha
um
i i think was uh fathers and sons by
tergenye
i must say i like things that are exotic
you know 19th century just like the best
movie that the russian movie was was
this just
uh which takes place in 19th century
russia on the bulgar river and stuff
like that so i like things that are
exotic
um
yeah
what else uh i personally like eduard
because when i started with my listening
improved good i completely agree i think
grammar is not something you have to
learn separately from language
it helps me with english for the tenses
okay
okay we've gone half an hour i have to
go golfing today so i'm going to cut it
off here i look forward to more
questions you can uh save them for next
time or else
just simply ask them on the youtube
channel
thank you very much bye for now